today I'm going to be talking about some
autonomous NASA robots and sort of the
records that they're breaking on Mars
and kind of a little bit about why we
care about that
first I thought I'd start with telling
you about those of you sort of many of
you work with JPL a little bit about
the JPL organizational structure because
it sort of has an impact on what I'll be
talking about so the banner on the top
it's showing artist concepts of
what the robotics organization does so
robotics is kind of like a department
sort of mechanical engineering or
computer science and we call that the
lion organization and so the people who
work in that would work on robotics
Concepts from like really early stage
ideas and research to actually
prototyping building the systems
iterating on them and then building the
hardware writing the software actually
testing it and then launching it and
running it on Mars so those are sort of
the things that people in that
organization would do
and at the bottom the banner I'm showing
an example of a project which is an
example is the Mars 2020 project which
is uh for example the Ingenuity
helicopter and the perseverance Rover so
on the projects you're dealing with all
the aspects for one Mission so from
launch to Landing entry descent Landing
parachutes Crews and the robotics is
part of it and there's science and
instruments but it's one aspect of a
bigger Mission so we work between these
and I have roles in both of these
organizations and you know there are
other examples of projects we've had
where robotics overlaps with the flight
projects and other examples are like the
Sojourner Rover
moreovers the Curiosity Rover on
perseverance and we've had some land
Admissions and the genuine helicopter so
essentially robotics is an aspect of
some of these missions and today
I was going to talk class I think I've
talked to some of you in individual
meetings more about of the other
projects we have like Cadre and Eels but
today I was going to focus more on the
Mars 2020 robotic aspects only I'm happy
to talk about others as as I chat with
more of you
and the parts about that that the
robotics really deals with is the
mobility and navigation so everything to
do with getting the Rovers from place to
place and the helicopter and the robotic
arm so we have a 2.1 meter arm which has
a turret at the end of it which is how
we position it close to the surface and
drill the surface or braid and position
instruments and then also a sampling
system which is primarily the reason
that this mission was sent to Mars they
it had the external arm collects and
drills cores but it docks with the body
of the Rover
inside which there is a second robotics
system and there's a second robotic arm
so the external arm transfers the tubes
in which we've collected the samples to
the internal system and then that goes
and measures them and seals them and uh
sort of deploys them later on to the
surface or transfers them to the next
Lander which is the primary part of the
mission and then there's also the
Ingenuity helicopter
and that is a new part of this Mission
so this is essentially a completely
separate robotic entity that we also
have as part of the mission
the other part that today I was going to
focus on is
perseverance is kind of this mission's
been fairly successful so far so already
we've collected 21 samples it can
collect a total of 43.
and the sample collection rate has been
about
going to Unique sites twice the rate of
any other mission that we had done
before so it's been really quite
productive
and then it's driven 17 kilometers and
what's really exciting is just how far
variable to go in us all so it's it's at
the record for the longest drive in a
single solve which is 319 meters but
what's kind of interesting about it is
before this the Rover that held the
record was the opportunity Rover which
was in 2005. so a really long time ago
that's like 17 years ago
and there was a lot of things that had
to come together for opportunity to set
that record and for a long time you know
curiosity never broke that record
and now with perseverance we've exceeded
that like over 20 times so what's what's
really exciting is we're getting to the
stage where it isn't just one-off that
we can drive hundreds of kilometers uh
hundreds of meters kilometers would be
great but it's starting to get pretty
consistent and that's actually the part
that's really exciting and then we're
also able to do multiple cell drives so
now we we communicate with Earth and
I'll go into it a little bit on a
infrequent basis but we can command it
without Earth contact back to back so we
can drive over multiple days and we've
gone about 700 meters
and most of this has actually been
autonomous driving and it's about 88 of
the driving and it varies you know it's
probably a slightly different number
today but on prior missions it was just
seven percent so this is an order of
magnitude mode driving is actually
autonomous driving
and then of course we have Ingenuity the
helicopter and now we're up to 47
flights that we've done with Ingenuity
and uh that's really exciting because
before this we didn't even know if we
could fly or the craft on Mars and now
we've covered quite a lot of distance uh
with with the rotorcraft
so go a little bit into you know in
general
the fact that we're doing this the
robotics is interesting but what drives
all of our missions is the science
behind it and so how is that
um how is that being impacted it's
trying to get me to join the network
but uh
so this image here is of Jezreel crater
so when perseverance was going to land
the scientists really wanted to go to
this location because we're looking for
signs of ancient life and the Delta is a
really likely place that you're going to
find that the problem is that the
landing ellipse needed to be pretty
small in order for us to land there and
in this image and it might be a little
bit small on the left side I'm showing
their The Landing ellipses and you can
just see the ovals get a sense
what they were for Sojourner and
curiosity and myrrh they were really
massive and if he had tried to land in
in
Jezreel we we would have been well
outside of the entire crater
the reason we could do this is even
though this crater has walls that are
fairly tall tens of meters and if you
land on the edge of a wall it's Hazard
we had capability on board that would
allow us to track so we had a prior map
on board and then as the Lander is
coming in it's taking images and
comparing and detecting where we're
actually headed
and as you'll see these are landmarks
being detected we were actually headed
toward a hazardous area and it's able to
in this uh detect that and Converge on a
solution detect that and it commanded a
divert so as the spacecraft is coming
down uh it was determined that we were
going to head towards it and so we ended
up diverting to the other side of the
Delta now this is great because this
spacecraft is safe and we were able to
land but at the same time this meant
that we were now
on the other side off the Delta from
this hazardous Zone and we were going to
need to get around it so in this image
here I'm kind of showing the three
campaigns which helped Define the
science part of the mission
so the Yellow Part the yellow oval is
where we landed on Cell zero and in the
beginning we the science mission was
interested in not that we're on the
crater floor let's go investigate and go
see what we can opportunistically find
here and then the next destination was
really to get to the blue area which is
the Delta which is why we'd come to Mars
and once we had finished the yellow area
crater flow campaign we just really
wanted to go as quickly as possible to
the other destination and
as you can see from this image I'm
showing the example that's it's a little
bit small but the dots the little
crosses are showing all the areas we
sampled and all the areas that we've
done science observations that the
science is really interested in and they
were mainly in the crater floor at the
bottom there and in the Delta and there
wasn't a lot of interesting features in
the rapid Traverse area getting from one
point to the other and every white dot
is a location the Rover has been at so
very quickly once we've done we started
driving all the way around and this is
where
the robotics really becomes very
valuable is you're not stuck to One
landing location at the same time you
want to go as fast as possible and the
spacing between those dots get larger
showing we did about 95 percent of that
drive autonomously
and for planetary robotics it was a big
deal we were able to cover the five
kilometers in less than a month and so
you know this is an area where the
scientists really started to build the
trust because this was exceeded the
expectations they didn't quite expect us
to get there this fast
and the reason this is a bit challenging
is most of you probably know but I still
find that you know it's very different
from terrestrial applications is we only
get to talk to the Rover about once a
day so we send commands and send the
instructions for the entire saw through
the deep space networks direct to the
Rover and then it'll collect information
and data and transmit it to orbiters and
sends it back to us because we are only
sending instructions once a day
it large and there's no communication to
see how monitoring of how that drive is
going or how any of the sample
collection is going it needs to be
largely autonomous and that's really
what is is the big reason we're able to
drive these long distances and break
these records is primarily because we've
been able to drive most of this
autonomously in this graph along the
x-axis you're seeing the salts the
number of salts
as the Rover has progressed and on the
y-axis is the cumulative drive distance
and the different colors are showing the
modes so we tend to have humans direct
from Earth sometimes when we're doing
Precision drives they're still really
good at that part but once you're going
over the horizons human can humans can't
see and so orange is the autonomous
driving and they're gradations of that
where there's some moderate amount of
supervision when we're doing visual
odometry or a guarded mouth
but this uh the area in the middle that
I'm the column that I'm showing is the
rapid Traverse and you can see we were
doing an exploratory fourways in the
beginning and then in the rapid Traverse
we really just drove and picked up a lot
of the autonomous navigation pace and
then continued on to continue to drive
autonomously
so how is it you know we've been driving
for so long on these with Mars rovers
why is it that we were able to make
sexually
and partly even more we were given the
problem that perseverance had to be what
NASA likes to call a built to print
Rover so essentially not a lot of the
infrastructure was going to change the
hardware
but yet we needed to draw wanted to
drive a lot faster so how do you take
the same motor control system the same
processor it's just a 133 megahertz
processor and try to add a lot of that
speed
so some of this was us you know
improving the algorithms but really
we've done that before and what really
made the difference was thinking about
it as to where the real bottlenecks were
and really strategically targeting those
so here are some of the examples
um the first was the wheels so we'd we'd
been on Mars for decades and we have
scientists who sort of specialize in
that terrain and yet none of them
predicted that we'd have these tiny tiny
rocks in uh when we were in Gale crater
with curiosity that are geometrically
not at all a hazard for the Rover but
they are sharp and they're volcanic in
origin and they're called Venta facts
and they started tearing up the
Curiosity wheels and we started to get a
lot of holes
and now it became interesting because
you're like you need to avoid these tiny
obstacles and the autonomous navigation
wasn't really set up to do that because
those are not obstacles as far as the
autonomy was concerned and we had
similar problems on myrrh where one of
the wheels got stuck on spirit and
opportunities wheel was towed in
making your autonomous algorithm now
completely change the model uh take some
time and so in these missions we started
to use less autonomy because the
autonomy wasn't actually driving the
vehicle in the ways we wanted so we
could have solved the problem by making
it more adaptable instead you know here
we took a simpler approach which is to
say just make the wheels more robust so
we don't have to worry about this stuff
and we could just drive over this so
this is an approach where you're like
instead of solving it by trying to
algorithmically coming up with a more
complex solution we came up with a
solution where we actually 3D printed
over 50 Wheels because it's really
expensive to build a single meal the
machine out of a single solid piece of
metal and we drove them for kilometers
in the merge yard in different designs
and eventually settled on this design
which has a little bit of a sinusoidal
curve on the wheels and slightly thicker
wheels and has you know slight other
design changes
and they've been doing really well and
allow us to not worry about the small
stuff essentially in the middle is like
the changes we made to the navigation
cameras so really improve the resolution
and also uh the exposure and speed so
now you don't have to worry about
slewing the Mast and trying to be clever
about how your image to fill in the gaps
the cameras can handle all of that with
single images so this was another way
where we really improved the Fidelity of
the maps
and then the last one which actually
tends to be the most important is the
Computing uh the computer we were kind
of needed because this is a what NASA
calls a Class B Mission which has a
certain risk tolerance
we just needed to have radiation
hardened computers and we were limited
to this really slow computer so instead
we put a second one we put a dedicated
computer just for the mobility system
and we did all the stereo and computer
vision processing in an fpgi so it was
you know hard coded but it allowed us to
get a lot of speed in that way well
relatively no speed
so with these Solutions we also
obviously needed to still improve the
algorithm and so there's a lot of
improvements in the path planning and
prediction of slup so in terrestrial
applications we don't worry about that a
lot but in Mars generally all vehicles
that are surface Vehicles slip is a huge
factor and how well you can predict it
so you can still be turning your wheels
and have an accurate estimate of where
it'll end up is very helpful
and then there are other things in the
middle I'm showing an actual Drive where
autonomous navigation is diverting and
one of the challenges used to be people
want to know where it ends up because I
need to communicate with Earth and I
need to know that it's a pointing where
it's RTG or any other part of the
Rover's body is not going to occlude
that view to Earth
uh so well we came up with autonomous
turn for calm whereas the Rover is
driving it knows where Earth is and
it'll turn to Earth and if it can't turn
to Earth of the location it which it is
it'll continue to drive until it can
find a spotted which can turn or uh you
know terminate and without doing that
endlessly
uh another thing that is is sort of like
Gyro's drift so we would start to accrue
uncertainty and we had to cap how far
that could go
because those bounds based on that we
made assumptions about hazards that we
specified to the Rover and also
Communications if your attitude deviates
too much you again can't communicate so
we have this approach where if it's if
it drifts too much it'll stop it'll find
the Sun and correct its attitude and
then continue driving so it uses Sun
finding as a way mid-drive to get more
accurate estimates so these are some of
the approaches that are not directly
tied to what we might classically think
of as you know improved navigation but
have really made a lot of the difference
and then there still are things you
can't do with um with the navigation yet
it's not that we can't do them it's just
we're constrained by schedule your
mission is going to launch you have to
test and verify and one of them ends up
being that um we do very well with
geometric obstacles which is you know
rocks craters edges of uh you know
Cliffs but texture is still sort of
challenging for vision-based approaches
and so instead of trying to solve all of
that problem what we do here is this is
actually a drive from Mars but this is
what we use to drive the Rover this is
the exact tool we use we have a menu of
options where we we create these
geometric patterns when the middle the
cyan and the yellow the magenta are the
path so a human operator will suggest a
path that's not the one that it's
actually going to follow if there's an
obstacle it'll deviate from it but it
doesn't have to solve the problem from
first principles also we keep these uh
rectangles you see the green as keep in
areas and the reds are don't bother to
figure it out I don't want you to hunt
and pack because it's seeing locally to
find a way around it I know it's not
going worth going into that area from
orbital maps on the ground so we have
these suggestions that we can provide it
but the uncertainty grows as it's moving
so we also have on the on the bottom
right showing a model where the
geometric Ops regions we tell it to keep
out of will grow so it factors in the
uncertainty so we don't have to worry
about in creating them at certain size
which we used to and factor in Oh by the
time the Rover gets here its pose will
have drifted so I need to make this fake
obstacle much larger
uh so it's able using this we solve the
problem of not having to make the
algorithm figure it out humans could do
it from Earth and it didn't have to be
precise the Rover on board can still
manage that and so these are the
approaches that have like really helped
us
um get some solve some of these
challenges and drive further distances
um this is a plot up to 562 Souls about
a year and a half into the mission of
all of the commands we have sent for
robotics
this is another approach we use where we
actually send moderate level granularity
commands so we may still send a waypoint
goal and have various knobs that we can
turn that we control from Earth these
are automatically generated so the
actual commanding is happening through a
very high level visual interface and it
auto-generates the low-level commands
but we can reconfigure them so here this
column is showing uh in purple all the
commands for Mobility so we're only
driving and the green is flying so we're
only driving and flying if we fly the
helicopter and drive at the same time on
the same salt
and this one on the left and the yellow
is the time when we were in the crater
floor and we would we've kind of got an
exploratory phase where you can see we
drive in purple some and then these
spikes are samples where we collected a
sample found it interesting went to a
different location so this is a very
exploratory phase and this is what we
want is doing more science on either end
and the driving is just a very small
duration where we're essentially
transporting from one place to the other
and in the Delta it's a slightly
different region on the right where we
knew that we wanted a sample this is
where we came for and you can see that
we have a very targeted sampling with
some finding the location that we want
to sample at it
but we actually uh have control over a
lot of the types of commands we may
generate in order to accomplish this and
this is something we're interested in
automatically exploring is we this is
still done with humans creating that
translation between the higher level to
the lower level and so you know we were
talking about things like language
models and others there's a lot of
potential here for making this more
automated and actually consistent
between different operators
um and then this is
um these are images of on the left of an
autonomous drive and those are the
actual images that the Rover uses to
navigate and this is soul 210
uh this is sort of you're seeing the
picture but what it doesn't show it's
just there's actually a lot of
occlusions and holes in these images
that it has to work with in order to
navigate
we rarely get down every frame we
actually spend most of our bandwidth to
get down science data so this is one of
the you know there are few drives where
we have all of the data otherwise we
take a sampling for engineering purposes
but otherwise mostly and it is sped up
this is uh and so essentially this is
about I I would say we took an image
every 30 seconds and so we've strung it
together in real time so it's about
probably 200 times better
so this is again another real drive that
we did on Mars This is around the South
you know we were seeing the South
theater region where it was a weekend
and we were doing a long drive where you
can see humans have suggested the path
and areas to keep out of but for three
days in a row the autonomous navigation
was following this path and you can see
it's deviating it found a little
obstacle that we had not specified from
the ground and it's working its way
around it and is able to find a path and
this resulted in driving over 500 meters
over the weekend with without actually
any intervening communication with Earth
then this is another example of the
sorts of drives where I was saying we
drove 700 meters where sometimes we are
not going to have any communication but
to get data down from ours but we can
send it new instructions
we so we're transmitting in the blind we
don't actually know where the previous
drive will end up because it's going to
be autonomous and we can string together
the drives we don't do this very
frequently because we might as well have
done it on the first day we planned and
just send the plan for many days in a
row
but the resource modeling can sometimes
get quite challenging and it takes you
want to have people on earth have a
normal work day and not be working you
know 18 hours so we might have them come
on multiple days even though they're
actually sending the plan up in chunks
and we're not actually we actually don't
know where anything has ended up we can
model the uncertainty so this is a case
where on the left you're seeing the
drive where the bigger circles show the
uncertainty growth and we're just
stringing them and what actually
happened on Mars is different from what
we simulated but within those bounds and
with this we can just say drive until
the time a certain time at which the
Orbiter is going to pass and it
continues to drive and this has worked
really well um uh to allow us to drive
really long distances and also allow
people sort of now people are becoming
the case where you're suggesting new
input you're not kind of controlling it
in a Serial Manner and as we get to the
outer planets that's going to be more
and more the case because when we get to
places like Europa and Enceladus you're
going to only communicate once every
week or less and for very short
durations
uh this here in the same path while we
were driving Ingenuity the helicopter it
can only talk to Earth by the Rover
because it doesn't have the power for
direct Earth communication so one of the
other challenges we have is we have to
always maintain line of sight between
the helicopter and the Rover so we
landed in this area where uh you know
the first flight occurred which was the
first time we could demonstrate whether
we could even fly
and one of the challenges with Ingenuity
was just can it survive the Martian
night it's a 1.8 kilogram vehicle and it
doesn't have a lot of heating and other
capability and so as we started to
realize it was going to be able to
continue flying we've had it follow the
Rover and in the South you can see it
did some scouting flights and then when
we were going to drive around
even though it can fly
700 meters 704 meters has been a long
flight in 90 seconds so it's a lot
faster than the Rover but it needs to
charge and there's a lot of things that
have to occur so actually the Rover at
the moment ends up being faster in
getting around to places than the
helicopter so when we were going to go
all the way around uh Ingenuity might
not have been able to keep up so it was
clear we were going to have to take a
shortcut for Ingenuity and that's what
we did is fly across but it becomes an
interesting robotics problem because you
have to ensure that every point with
uncertainty because you're going to fly
and drive either can fail that it can
always communicate so we have these Maps
which you're seeing in the inside on the
left where we do these
telecommunications link strength so you
know where the regions are where it's
going to be able to communicate
at the moment this is done on the ground
this is another thing we would like to
do on board so that you can eventually
because if you're going to have these
vehicles communicate and keep track of
you know doing scouting we're going to
need to do more of this on board
and so what got interesting was
Ingenuity did make it to the Delta as
did perseverance
but when we got there uh it was starting
to be the Martian winter so the Mars
euro is about twice as long because Mars
is further from the Sun and takes it uh
two years two Earth years to get around
the Sun well it was Winter now and we
knew we were going to have some trouble
with Ingenuity because it's such a small
spacecraft
and in the bottom here I'm showing the
graph where in red is our predictions
for how its charge was going to evolve
and on the x-axis is El sebast so
elsabes is you know the song solar
longitude and it's essentially track
it's it you can think of it as the
seasons on Mars and so we knew that as
winter and fall came it was going to dab
but it actually got to be a lot worse
than we expected it to be so on salt for
we would started a lot you know you want
the avionics on a spacecraft to not get
too low because generally savionics if
they freeze you don't know if they're
going to recover from that because the
Mars temperature is really low we
started lowering the set point so it
used to be you know minus 15 made it
minus 20 minus 25. it was still not
enough and so essentially uh you know we
lost contact and the Ingenuity kind of
entered a load shed low power mode
and at that point it's lost track of its
clock it doesn't know what time it is so
when it wakes up we have a particular
time at which we would know we would
have set the alarm to say this is the
time which the Rover is going to contact
you and you sort of hail the vehicle
while it was not going to know what time
it is so we would wake up the Rover and
we just started hunting so when
Ingenuity is going to wake up so that
you can track and communicate with it
well it didn't wake up right away and
essentially it would wake up just enough
and get enough power
and then it would freeze again and so it
was essentially going through these
Cycles but eventually we we did we call
this capture now so we actually still
fly it this way so in the it it sort of
has Amnesia loses track of its time
every night and in the morning we have
now quite precisely figured out when
it's going to wake up you have a good
model of it so we about spend an hour
doing what we call a capture so we
capture it to say this is the time and
then we set its clock to when we want to
fly because flying on Mars you want to
do it particular times because that's
when
um the density is the right and the wind
speeds are correct so then the SEC we've
set its clock and then we'll fly next
time us all again we will capture it
again and then we'll fly it so that's
kind of how we're doing it until things
get better so uh you know you can see
the flights here got a lot smaller and
I'm showing you flight 29 30. we were
starting to do very small hops mostly
you know we were lucky because
perseverance was in the Delta and mostly
doing sampling link there so it wasn't
very far away
but Ingenuity was able to sort of
recover and get get more energy and we
are entering into better season
through about until September was like
really challenging but we're finding
that it's actually accumulated more dust
on its solar panel originally every time
it would fly the dust would kind of blow
off but now the latest images which I'll
show you a video we took just this week
it's starting to accumulate more dust
and that means less charge
uh
and so you know while it was doing this
we really went to Mars the biggest thing
that perseverance is doing is collecting
intact sample cores because
we will we we're looking for signs of
life and Earth laboratory we've gotten
Laboratories we've sent to Mars and done
analysis but really Earth has like so
much more ways to analyze this so this
is the time we want to collect and bring
them back so this is an example of a
rock Webby uh by a show where we've
drilled it and on the right you're
seeing a cross-section we do take some
video images on Earth but it's much
easier in the test pad to see so this is
an example where I sh where I'm showing
in one of our Chambers we try to create
the right pressure and temperature where
this is a tube we picked up from inside
the Rover uh from with the second
robotic arm inside passing it onto it we
have this bit Carousel which rotates we
have multiple bits that we can switch
for coring and operating and it moves it
out there's uncertainty with respect to
where the ground is so we have something
called an FCS a facility contact so to
remove the uncertainty mechanically we
touch the surface we know exactly where
it is in the Z in the tool frame even if
we don't if you have some lateral error
which we actually remove with vision
based closed-loop
accuracy adjustment then we can our
relative accuracy is pretty good so when
we switch from one tool to the other we
have reasonably accurately know where
the surface is because the science team
will when they're really interested
they're like I want to go to this vein I
want to go to a feature that is two
millimeters you're dealing with 100
kilogram arm with all of its um uh
uncertainties
and then we drill into the surface this
has been quite interesting and I'll show
you some results uh and uh we are trying
to collect intact cores you can see the
tailings start to come about and this is
another thing that we have to model for
subsequent placements because we put
instruments that have very delicate
lenses later on to study features and
you want to make sure they don't sort of
Hit the tailings we uh you know can get
the arm back in position we take the
images you're seeing of the Cross
sections we take by rotating the arm and
actually just positioning the arm and
looking at it
and in different positions
and then after that we sort of go back
to the bit Carousel and on the Rover's
body and we dock with it we have some
cones that can be used to guide the
positioning and then we transfer the
tube inside I'm not showing the video of
what happens inside but there's a second
robotic arm that pulls it it weighs it
images it and then seals it these seals
need to be pretty good because they've
got to survive up to 10 years on the
surface of Mars potentially and then
Earth re-entry when they're going to
come back so that's kind of you know the
coring operation
and in this graph which is again maybe a
little small but you can see along the
x-axis are all the salts these are some
of the cores we've taken and on the Y
uh there are three different you know
plots so
we have the commanded depth that we want
to go typically you know these are about
the size of a chalk the cores but and
then what it actually occurs because the
rock can be very hard though it can be
very soft so we actually use adaptive
drilling because we don't want to wait
and figure out what it is and then
command the next day with adjusted
parameters we do it closed loop well if
you might have noticed you know the
green is the actual length we achieved
as we measured it in image the first one
there's no green because we got no
sample so after all the testing we have
like the world specialist and all the
rocks and we drilled all the variety of
rocks they'd given us probably 40 or 50.
the very first sample that we drilled it
completely pulverized and we looked at
the sample and was empty so the way that
the composition of the rock was
it literally crumbled with the drilling
and resulted in all tailings we adjusted
it and subsequently we've gotten our
intact core so again you know you do all
of the testing and literally the very
first sample and it's different from all
of the modeling and testing
and then another one where you see this
Paul sample well there is no sample
there either what happened there was we
got an intact core we docked with the
Rover's body
and it started to crumble and pieces of
it fell into that red Carousel where
you're seeing it rotate and it resulted
in not being able to move so we ended up
throwing that sample away clearing it
out and then again modified the fact
that we wouldn't we we used to try to
ingest the sample because there was some
mushrooming that could occur that we
wanted to avoid but we adapted that so
we wouldn't we would reduce the
potential of it cobbling
so you know this data has really helped
us see it actually provides information
about what the composition of those
rocks is physically and then we also
Place instruments we have an x-ray
diffraction uh instrument and a Roman
spectrometer on the surface
but the surface is not very interesting
to scientists because it's weathered
it's exposed so they want to get below
it so we cut a little circle with a
drill a bit about a five centimeter
Circle and then we have a little tank of
nitrogen gas we blow away the dust and
then position the instruments in it here
you're seeing again all the abrasions
we've done along the x-axis and along
the y-axis is the level that we had to
achieve of a product to do it mostly it
stuck to the model and then we reached
the delta and even before just in the
very initial you know uh
mode The Rock started cracking and it
was just too soft the rocks of the Delta
were too soft so we had to this is where
humans adjusted the point at which we
start the prodapt algorithm and why
won't we always do that and partly
because you know we can't replace our
bits on Mars and if they start to dull
we don't want to just do rotary we want
to have some percussive element and so
we don't unless the rock is soft we
don't just start at a very low mode so
we are able to you know get a number of
sample so as a result of this we now had
quite a representative set of samples so
you could see these are all you know
very different varieties of cores that
we've collected from different parts of
the delta
these were interesting enough that the
scientists were getting really excited
about it now you know they're all inside
the Rover if the Rover was to fail
they're all sort of still inside the
Rover and so we don't want that to
happen so one of the strategies this is
the Mars sample return overall mission
architecture so the first leg of it is
what perseverance is doing where it
launched it's collected a set of samples
what the next phase is in 2028 another
mission is going to launch and this is a
joint collaboration with NASA and Esa
the European Space Agency
and on that is going to be a Lander this
is quite a massive Lander because it's
carrying a rock at two Mars so that we
can launch these samples back from ours
and it's also carrying two helicopters
based on Ingenuity but those helicopters
have wheels and a robotic arm on them
and the reason is that if say
perseverance were to die we don't want
all the samples in it so so far in the
mission it collected two of each sample
one it dropped on the ground to save in
a cache so that the helicopters could
fly and pick it up the rest is
continuing to carry and it's going to
carry to the Lander and transfer them
directly so that'll be a full cache set
but we have a backup deposited
there's another spacecraft that launches
a year before in 2027 which is called by
the European Space Agency called the
Earth return Orbiter and that then once
we finish all the tubes we put them in a
canister and launch them into Mars orbit
and rendezvous with that so essentially
we have another robotic system
that captures uh from the earth return
Orbiter it's essentially captures this
canister around Mars orbit and then we
come back to earth and bring them back
to Earth so this is why now that we had
a rich enough cache of samples the
scientists were ready to be like let's
get them on the ground because we don't
want to lose them so that's what we
recently did so this pattern here shows
this is the Rover the path of the Rover
where we were depositing the samples we
put 10 of them on the ground why would
we do this in this particular pattern
and I think it's a little faint here but
you'll see around each sample location
is a is a disk that shows a helicopter
landing pad for each location even
though for perseverance or something the
scale of a Rover this is kind of really
benign terrain it's like all completely
open but for helicopters which
you know Ingenuity weighs 1.8 these
helicopters including the wheels and arm
are supposed to weigh about 2.3
kilograms
these would be hazards small tiny
Pebbles so we had to ensure there'd be
no pebbles in the region around which we
dropped them so perseverance had to drop
them five meters apart about five meters
and so these are all the tubes we've
dropped and all the locations at which
we've dropped them and they're now on
the surface so it's essentially you know
kind of the mission is kind of
is success in a way because we we have
something to bring back
and now here is the locations that we've
been so far in the small uh wedge on the
right side and this is the planned
Mission so it's almost like 10 times as
much driving as we've done before is in
the plan for the future as we crawl our
way onto the Delta out and Beyond
so we really there's a lot we can do
with this and as it's here actually is
uh this week's uh sort of image earlier
from the of the week of Ingenuity so
this is ingenuity's latest flight so
this is the Rover taking a picture with
its camera off with a high resolution
you're seeing the helicopter if you
could see a little bit of a faint there
flying in the sky and uh we'll continue
on you can see it's it's a little Dusty
now but it's continuing to um uh you
know carry along taking uh following the
Rover and that's the hope is that it'll
be able to keep up and Scout ahead so we
continue to
have there are certain locations that we
have these branching points I showed you
and so the helicopter would be able to
go and pick some of those routes for us
um
let's see so one of the interesting
things about this is as we get into this
part of the mission is what can we do to
make things better because we want to
try and go further and faster
so Ingenuity has a processor on it so
the Rover has to have radiation hardened
processes but because Ingenuity was a
technology demonstration it didn't have
a stringent requirements so it kind of
has a commercial Snapdragon 801
processor so the Ingenuity has more
Computing than all of the Rovers we've
sent to Mars combined so essentially
that little helicopter is like massively
uh you know has a lot of resources and
it's flying Linux so it's great
but what we have is in addition to the
helicopter having a computer there's
also a computer on the base station so
for the for Ingenuity to talk to
perseverance it does it through a base
station that is mounted on the Rover
that has another processor that I'm
showing here
what we'd like to do and what we're
working on is using that for Rover
Computing essentially as a co-processor
to say I'm going to ship off Computing
to this processor that is very capable
and some of the things we're interested
in is what are now some of the
bottlenecks for us to actually even
break further and drive more and some of
what we are seeing is there are cases
where we end rise so these are all the
faults that we've ever had in drives on
Mars and some of them are the obvious on
the right
this is a graph on souls and on the
right you're seeing slip so one of some
of them are related to slap because we
encountered more slip than we expected
but others are no path where it didn't
find a path through and currently we
think of this as an expected case and
I'll show you some of the reason why
so this is the same drive I was showing
you on Mars where we're trying to drive
a very long distance over three Souls
and in the dark blue is the uncertainty
growth so as we are driving the Rover's
uncertainty is growing and by the time
it gets to this location
these red obstacles these red areas are
what humans say to keep out of it
essentially doesn't have a path through
it's it's completely blocked off because
if it's uncertainty through that
corridor
but if we do Global localization we're
on board it takes images of the
surrounding terrain Compares it to a
global map then you reduce that
uncertainty currently we do this on the
ground because it's so computationally
expensive but we could do this on the
Rover and so if we had something like
this co-processor we're looking at doing
that
but it's it's it's it's relatively
challenging on the left you're seeing
this image which is the image taken from
the Rover's vantage point
and on the right is that orbital map at
that on that same scale so the
resolution between those two is quite
different and so feature matching or
even you know correlation uh is is
interesting
and then the other challenge is this is
a pan through of a 360 nav cam image
around the Rover and there are a lot of
occlusions and holes in it so that's the
other challenge is either it might be
there may be no features if you know
featureless terrain or uh it's it's
rather noisy but we're this is this is
one of the problems that we're we're
working on and are very interested in
continuing to solve
some of the other problems are detecting
sand so we would we currently detect
just geometric obstacles but if he could
very accurately detect sand on board
then we don't have to tell it from the
ground which regions to keep out of it
could do that on board
uh and I think some of the other
approaches is on the ground we're doing
this generative path planning this is
also something that we could
automatically have the algorithm on
board do which is select the waypoints
and generate the path because then you
can then you can do that on board with
additional information and be able to
drive even longer distances
so I think I was just going to show a
video of sort of the mar actually I'm
going to turn the volume off but this is
a video of the Mars sample return
Mission which I just talked about
which shows you know the perseverance
Rover after it's collected the samples
finishing collecting and then driving to
the location where the Mars sample
return Lander will will land and driving
up to it so it'll be fairly close
because this Landing is going to be
Pinpoint Landing so here instead of just
avoiding an obstacle it's actually doing
visual navigation to a particular Point
transfer the tubes to it and then this
is the canister in which the tubes are
sampled and then once it is filled up it
closes that canister and then you
launches the samples from Morris and
Rendezvous in Mars orbad to bring those
samples back from Earth and so that uh
you know that's going to be a really you
know the Rover is going to potentially
be able to watch the rocket launch which
should be uh which be really interesting
uh to have
pardon
yes we don't want to fry the robot but
actually it's interesting because of
that reason it actually the you if you
saw the rocket it doesn't do a vertical
liftoff it lifts off and then does it
does it at an angle and then yeah so
this is kind of the overall mission that
we're working towards and I thought I'd
take any questions if you have them
[Applause]
thank you very much
there are a lot of questions
who wants to start
something like
well at least you can ask the question
through the mic so that the people that
are working kind of scary questions so
you talked about how
um there's radiation uh radiation
hardened components on the Rover itself
and then you put um commercial
components on the helicopter how did the
commercial components survive so well
and uh within the radiation environment
on Mars
yeah so we've actually it's a you know
that's one of the things we sort of
asked the question about is can the cots
component survive and what we'll see so
we have definitely seen one guaranteed
single event up set with the helicopter
and there were a few cases where we
didn't get the data back to no if we
actually had a radiation issue or not so
that is uh but you know we've still seen
some of them and that if it were to
occur something like that at the time
you're doing something like an entry
descendant Landing that's kind of the
end of mission uh so that we're working
on approaches
to do software-based mitigations now so
looking at approaches where you know of
course there is the usual voting and
doing multiple versions of it but
there's additional approaches we're
looking at so we can use these really
much more capable computers even you
know while mitigating that variation
risk
s do you have any fun stories from
driving the Rover right oh yeah so lots
of uh so I think one of the drives which
you know it's a really short drive but
really it's interesting was the Davey
dropped the helicopter so the helicopter
made its way to Mars trapped under the
Rover and at some point we had to deploy
the helicopter and essentially that was
interesting because it's getting its
power from the Rover
it we had to fire these um bowls it was
a frangible that it was attached
and it it's you know one leg at a time
would come down and then drop it but now
it doesn't have power from the Rover and
if the Rover doesn't drive off of it it
can't charge and it won't survive the
night so that drive really had to work
and yet we realized that there was
particularly uncertainty that that
frangible may not have fire and you
don't want a dangling helicopter and
driving so this got very interesting we
actually ended up doing we ended up
writing a patch we ended up writing a
dotto that we sent to the spacecraft
right before helicopter deploy that
would allow us to check that state and
do a direct-to-earth communication to
just know if that would happen so that
we could abort that drive but that was a
very interesting drive also just the
amount of things we thought about we
ended up driving uh you know whether to
drive backwards or forwards and things
like that
yeah all right so you mentioned uh
pointing the Rover uh towards Earth uh
what about the orbiting relays and we
were supposed to get one in 2022 and we
didn't uh what's the status for the
orbiting assets
yeah that's a you know really good
question so essentially because we get
so much data from ours we don't send it
direct we send it to the uh relays so we
use the high gain antenna which is
pointable for Earth but we have
omnidirectional UHF antenna with which
we talk to the orbiters so we don't have
to worry as much about that but we have
had you know we had we currently have
Odyssey and we have major Constance
Orbiter uh and uh this is going to be
interesting but the sample return
mission where that Earth return Orbiter
is also a relay but it's going to have
an interesting so the orbit that these
spacecraft take around Mars impacts the
time that we have available uh so that's
going to mean that ero is interesting it
actually is going to communicate so that
we get the data down at Earth at about
the same time even though it's going to
be a different time on Mars but we won't
have
the current space orbiters are not
expected to last as long so this this
limits what we can do so once ero goes
the question becomes does perseverance
have uh Orbiter to communicate with
Earth with so that's definitely you know
some of the things is how long the
orbitals last
together
um so for the path planning uh for like
the recommended paths for the Rover to
take and also for the geographic areas
for the Rover to avoid why are all those
um like shapes like geometric shapes
like circles and rectangles and
triangles why aren't they more like
organic to match the geography of the
Martian terrain yeah that's good you
know generally the terrain is organic so
again simplicity so essentially
for human operators the tools it's
easier to have something that you just
specify so the flight it's represented
in the onboard flight software and if
you had free form shapes you would have
to have more complex data structures
whereas if you have a rectangle or a
circle you limit
the sort of option space you have to
specify it but this is again interesting
right because you're you're not being
optimal if you're simplifying it and
there's a trade-off between what's
necessary and so you know what what sort
of does the job or not but that's the
reason primarily just to keep it simple
foreign
thanks for the great talk by the way
um so how does your team deal with uh
motor failures or like let's say Motors
being stuck while it's working or doing
the sampling and has it happened before
in the whole journey so far
yeah no that's another good question so
yeah that tends to be one of the so you
know we actually categorize our faults
there are certain things we call a goal
error where there was a logical error or
some you could find a path and then we
have others which we call motion errors
which is anything to do with the motor
control system or a piece of Hardware
had a stuck fault so we we tend to have
both a hard stop on the motors but we
also have a soft star so we'd rather hit
the software stop before we actually
mechanically well uh and so we can
detect stalls and that pretty much all
our Rovers we've had it happen at some
point and it essentially will be some
weird configuration of the rock you
encounter or you're trying to go over
some terrain so you might stall
and other areas might just be some
race condition or the error motor
control you know at that regular rate at
which it's operating with freeform
terrain when that happens
we have a lot of ways to detect it and
it stops with a motion error that's an
error we don't tend to clear because
there can be so many explanations you
could actually have an actual fault that
we didn't understand so that is one
where we currently have Earth in the
loop where the Rover will stop and then
on Earth we look at the data and then
decide if we want to collect diagnostic
data often with the motor control fault
we might it actually Auto Collects some
amount of Diagnostics so it's when it
knows it has a fault it collects High
array data if that's sufficient we might
drive the next day otherwise we might
collect more you know but yeah
those do occur depending on you know
what kind of terrain you're driving on
again there were going to be a lot of
questions
um so you mentioned a few areas of
autonomy that
um kind of make perseverance stand out
as compared to past drivers I'm curious
what the biggest area like what the
biggest Gap is between what's currently
on perseverance and what we would need
for like a dragonfly in terms of
autonomy right right
so you know I touched on a few of them
there's other areas that I didn't like
we do also autonomous science like at
the end of a drive we take an image in
that we detect what an interesting rock
is and we sort of autonomously shoot the
laser at it
um so there's you know various the
science you need to start doing the
science more more of the science
autonomously too
I think the areas you would need for
something like Titan for for uh
dragonfly mission is
sort of Landing site selection so when
you're going to a location is it say you
know we can we currently everything we
fly with Ingenuity on from Earth we
detect what the safe landing sites are
with the uncertainty you'll have we are
putting uh we have on board the software
now for its ability to divert from what
it thinks is an unsafe land inside so
that would be one and then another would
be just
potentially you know stringing together
those waypoints and picking the next
point I don't think dragonfly entirely
needs to do that you could end up going
to one location doing the sampling and
then flying off and doing
but those would be some of the areas
where you you really want to be able to
very robustly detect locations that are
safe to land or not
thank you of course it's a fascinating
discussion and we could keep going for
another hour or so but we had to leave
the room for the next class so thank you
again Andy and uh that was a great way
to end the quarter